voilà ce petit moment que certains
attendent avec impatience tous les mois
ce petit moment que d'autres fuient tous
les mois mais regarde quand même
malheureusement alors aujourd'hui trois
nouvelles histoires trois nouveaux
témoignages de gens qui ont vécu un truc
très creepy dans leur vie encore une
fois il n'est toujours pas question de
paranormal de surnaturel il est question
juste d'humains chelou oppressant
bizarre menaçant dont malheureusement
certaines personnes ont croisé la route
et ça a donné une expérience de la
manche le loup est un peu traumatisant
on commence tout de suite avec inès inès
il ya trois ans elle avait 25 ans et
elle décide de s'inscrire sur une
application de rencontre un peu comme
beaucoup de gens de son âge
quelques jours après elle tombe sur un
profil d'un mec qui lui plaît un mec un
peu geek se sont profilés à les photos
de ses voyages de ses randonnées bref il
lui tape dans l'oeil comme on dit si je
peux me permettre
alors elle fait le pas elle lui envoie
un message il lui répond puis se mettent
à discuter ils échangent même leurs
numéros petit bémol comme le mec à qui
parle inès n'habite pas dans la même
ville qui naissent ils habitent assez
loin et du coup il lui dit que bah ils
comptent pas du tout se rendre dans la
ville d'in est ce donc que probablement
il se rencontreraient jamais mis la
salle explique que sa salle a séduit
parce qu'elle se dit [ __ ] le mec il
est honnête le feeling passe bien j'en
ai conscience il en a conscience mais il
me dit clairement qu'il n'a pas le temps
de venir me voir dans ma ville
bref chacun sa technique pour plaire à
une fille on n'est pas là pour parler de
ça quelques semaines plus tard bonnes
surprises et nas reçoit un message de
tom dans lequel il lui dit qu'il est
dans un bar de sa ville parce qu'il
avait un rendez vous professionnel
du coup du propose de le rejoindre dans
le bar pour enfin ils se rencontrent et
que peut-être ce soit le début d'un
amour fou
plutôt cool comme il lui plaît vraiment
donc elle se dit bon basique gaulle
rencontré et au pire c'est un tocard et
c'est pas grave tu vois il ya plein de
premier rendez vous qui se passe pas
bien on est déçu et puis on voit plus la
personne et c'est réglé tom lui propose
de venir la chercher chez elle en
voiture et inès malheureusement
acceptent ces mots elle explique que
malheureusement elle a accepté
ils ne se retrouvent dans la voiture de
tom et elle grille que c'est une voiture
de location et que c'est pas sa voiture
il est censé venir d'une autre ville
tête qu'il a pris le train est qu en
arrivant il a loué une voiture pour
enchaîner ces rendez vous pros c'est
aussi possible
inès attention la paranoïa ils vont
chercher une place pour se garer autour
du bar pendant 10 minutes mais y'en a
pas donc tom demande à eynesse de lui
dire où aller pour qu'ils puissent se
garer
inès très beau réflexe choisi le parking
d'un centre commercial sur lequel il ya
toujours plein de voitures et pas mal de
gens qui passent elle est quand même
dans la voiture d'un mec qu'elle connaît
pas qu'elle a jamais vu donc c'est quand
même ma lin de couvrir ses arrières et
faire en sorte qu'il y ait des gens qui
puissent le voir si jamais ça se passe
mal il arrive enfin dans ce bar est
aussitôt arrivé aussitôt de tom essaie
de faire boire
inès tom insiste insiste alors elle
prend un verre puis un deuxième
énormément c'est pas son genre d'armes
ans quand le mec force un peu elles se
cassent tout de suite à l'arête mais là
elle explique qu'il lui plaisait
suffisamment pour qu'elle continue cette
soirée avec lui deuxième move très malin
d'inès dans le bar il ya une vieille
connaissance elle alors elle va
l'interpeller pour que cette
connaissance voit tom est en fait elle
explique que sur le moment elle a eu un
réflexe un peu de parano mais un peu
malin où elle s'est dit vas-y ce gars là
je le connais quand même pas c'est quand
même cool si une connaissance à moi m'a
vu avec lui et a vu son visage si jamais
il se passe un truc pas bien moi je
trouve ça dingue de penser ça mais de
continuer le rendez-vous gens mais si tu
es dans une parano pareil arrête tout
rentre chez toi
simon stop après 1h30 de conversation
c'est la fin du rendez vous inédit atom
basse était cool vas-y gérante et la
tomme insiste pour qu'ils aillent tous
les deux bois un café de l'autre côté de
la rue pour se dégriser un peu inès
troussage seul ou parce qu'ils sont pas
restés vraiment longtemps dans ce bar
ils n'ont pas vraiment beaucoup plus
bref c'est bizarre d'aller taper un café
après ce à quoi du coup ils naissent
elle refuse et elle change de sujet pour
le distraire et finir sur une note
agréable dans la discussion tom expliqué
hoeness qui l'a loué un airbnb pas très
loin de la ville et lui propose de venir
finir la soirée chez lui puisqu'il y vit
seule inès lui sort des noms très poli a
maintenant je fatiguais à mais tu sais
demain je dois me lever tôt à vous
connaissez tout ça mais à chaque fois
qu'il ya un truc tome il a un argument
contraire pour lui dire si si tu vas
venir vient de laver ainsi s'il vient au
bout d'un moment il n'est celle trouve
the parade et lui dit ok je veux pas
venir mais vas-y si tu veux tu me
ramènes chez moi quelle erreur et ciao
normalement qu il force à ce point le
mec c'est fini une fois dans la voiture
tombée en train de conduire et il dit à
inès attend c'est quoi on va s'arrêter
au supermarché comme ça tu vas pouvoir
d'acheter quelques affaires et tu seras
plus confort chez moi qu'est-ce que tu
ne comprends pas top
la inès el bugs elle se dit attend et ce
qui fait exprès de pas comprendre où est
ce que juste on s'est mal compris et je
me suis pas bien exprimé je n'existe pas
pendant ce temps tom continue de rouler
et il s'approche d'une zone rurale dans
laquelle il n'y a aucun supermarché
c'est bon aucun inès au pied du mur
tente le tout pour le tout et lui dit
écoute mec vraiment je t'ai dit je veux
pas du tout aller chez toi donc ramène
moins chez moi je te plaît comme prévu
tome reste cool et lui dit non mais
t'inquiète on va passer une bonne soirée
en plus des propriétaires du airbnb sont
vraiment sympa tu vas voir on va trop
s'amuser ce qui paralyse complètement de
peur ines étant donné que souvenez-vous
quelques minutes avant il lui avait
clairement dit qu'il était seul dans ce
airbnb inès change donc de stratégie
elle lui dit ah ok bon ok vas-y ça va
être cool mais avant est ce qu'on peut
faire un petit détour par chez moi pour
que je prenne mon pyjama et des
médicaments je suis obligé de prendre
tous les jours
alors je sais pas comment elle a aussi
des menaces parce que entre la pression
du mec bizarre le fait d'être dans une
zone rurale
où il n'ya rien même pas de lumière etc
faut vraiment être très quoi je pourrais
avoir une improbable par chance tom
accepte et il fait demi tour une fois
presque arrivés tome 10 à ines qui va
monter avec elle dans son appart pour
les dmc ses phrases horrible où le gars
qui fait genre d'être gentil
bienveillant et tout mais c'est juste
hyper mal placé et hyper intrusif genre
tu sent tout de suite que ça y'a un truc
qui va pas à ce moment-là inès elle est
encore en voiture avec lui et elle se
dit [ __ ] qu'est ce que je réponds à ça
parce que à tout moment là il refait
demi-tour il m'emmène dans les bois et
et c'est un malade quoi qu'est ce qu'il
va faire et pendant qu'elle réfléchit il
arrive à un stop et il ya des gens qui
traversent la route en les voyant ines
elle descend de la voiture très très
vite mais très calme elle expliqué à
thomas qu'elle a trop mal au crâne qui
est lui enverra des messages mec là elle
a juste envie de dormir elle ferme la
porte avant même que tom lui répondent
et elle fonce très très vite dans un
parc dans lequel la voiture de tom ne
peut pas passer arrivés aux abords du
parc elle regarde discrètement derrière
elle que tom ne descend pas de la
voiture pour la suivre à pied et non il
est bien là au volant de sa voiture
furax
mais ils bougent pas inas explique qu'il
l'avait bloqué sur l'appli de rencontres
dans l'heure qui suit et elle explique
avec le recul elle pense que s'il a
autant insisté pour son histoire de café
c'est qu'il voulait qu'elle reçoive
quelque chose dans lequel il aurait pu
glisser éventuellement un truc de merde
comme ghb enfin bref une drogue du
connard là pour profiter d'elle elle
pense aussi que si lui a dit dans
l'appli qui l'habitait pas dans cette
ville et qui compte et ne jamais s'y
rendent donc il se verrait probablement
jamais c'était uniquement pour couvrir
ses arrières et qui est zéro traces dans
l'appli du fait qu'ils se soient
rencontrés et au delà de ça c'est
surtout un feeling il ya des gens des
fois tu as vraiment pas un bon feeling
tu dis vraiment là y'a un truc qui est
bizarre qui est pas normal y est ça
cloche là mais quand même type note
positif entre temps ça n'a pas effrayé
mais c'est l'art fait des rencontres sur
ce tapis l'on en compte et elle y a même
rencontré son fiancé bravo moi je
devrais jamais relancé l'apli il est
temps de passer à la seconde histoire
qui elle ne parle pas du tout d'appeler
dans le conte c'est l'histoire de victor
qui commence d'abord par donner tout le
contexte il vit avec ses parents dans
une belle et grande maison qui est plus
ou moins foutu en deux parties il ya une
partie type très bel appartement au
premier étage il ya une seconde partie
au sous-sol avec garage buanderie et
c'est un jour le père de victor décide
de faire installer des climatiseurs le
lendemain il ya donc pas mal d'employés
qui viennent il ya une partie à
l'intérieur il ya une partie dehors pour
installer les fameux compresseur vous
savez qu'on voit partout à l'extérieur
des maisons et des appartements aux
états unis d'ailleurs enfin bref il ya
beaucoup de passage et ce jour là du
coup la mère de victor et victor
lui-même décide d'aller faire des
courses et de pas être à la maison parce
que bahia du bruit du monde bref c'est
chiant le père de victor en revanche
reste dans la maison pour diriger les
ouvriers victoire et sa maman rentre le
soir après
avoir fait des courses un petit resto
bref une petite sortie entre mary fils
et le père de victor est déjà au lit
parce que les travaux l'ont complètement
crevé donc victor et sam amandine tous
les deux devant un film à l'étagé dans
la partie appartement de leurs maisons
après avoir dîné victor demande à sa
mère d'aller garer la voiture au parking
parce qu'elle s'était juste mis devant à
larache et sa mère quant à elle lui
demande d'aller vérifier que la porte
d'entrée est bien fermée à double tour
parce que beaucoup de passagers beaucoup
de gens qui sont venus dans la maison
aujourd'hui pour cette histoire de
climatiseurs victor va tchèque et c'est
pas le cas la porte n'est pas du tout
fermé à clé et elle est même un peu
entrouverte bon pour lui rien
d'inquiétant il dit qu'ils ont mal
claqué en arrivant il a fermé à double
tour et il remonte à l'étagé ils se
remettent devant leurs films et quelques
minutes plus tard victor il entend un
bruit sourd venir du sous-sol de la
buanderie plus précisément il explique
qu'il n'était pas inquiet parce qu'en
fait ils ont un chat et que souvent ce
chat quand il a faim quand il veut que
victor lui donne à manger il fait des
conneries classique djomo veut la même
chose donc je vois très bien le truc et
même vous vos chats font la même chose
c'est sûr à mi chemin dans les escaliers
qui mènent à cette fameuse buanderie
victor il entend un autre bruit souffre
cette fois ci plus fort que le premier
qu'il avait entendu il se dit bon bah
c'est sûrement mon chat il m'entend
arrivée il pense que j'ai la gamelle
dans les mains donc il est tout excité
il fait encore plus de conneries victor
ouvre la porte du sous sol et il n'ya
pas son chat ce qui est d'autant plus
embêtant c'est que d'habitude quand il
ouvre la porte sont chaque cours vers
lui parce qu'il est content de le voir
et surtout d'avoir très prochainement de
la bouffe victor entrent dans la
buanderie et là son coeur arrête de
battre parce que la porte du placard est
fermé attendez manque une info victor et
ses parents ne ferme jamais la porte du
placard
c'est même une instruction du père de
victor parce qu'il ya des souris qui
régulièrement se planque dans le placard
et ils veulent que leur chat puissent
aller dans le placard pour les
débarrasser de ces souris il comprend
donc que le gros boom qui l'a entendu
c'était sûrement la porte du placard qui
a été claquée il se retrouve donc seul
au sous sol face à ce placard en étant
convaincu que quelqu'un se cachent à
l'intérieur il veut juste pas donner une
raison à cette personne d'ouvrir la
porte aux quelque 1 victor se
retrouverait en danger puisqu'il verrez
le visage de ces personnes est donc ces
personnes auraient des raisons de s'en
prendre à lui et là victor il fait un
move de gym hockey de génie déjà il fait
genre qu'il a rien remarqué de bizarre
ici flotte tranquille et il se met à
parler avec une voix de bébé un peu gaga
à son chat alors que son chat n'est pas
là il sort sa meilleure prestation
d'acteur pendant qu'il fait ça il recule
peu à peu vers les escaliers en gardant
bien entendu les yeux rivés sur cette
[ __ ] de portes de placards et réussi à
ré atteindre démarche et
france pour expliquer à sa mère ce qui
vient de se passer et ce qu'ils pensent
qui se passe actuellement dans la
buanderie de sa mère bien entendu le
prend pas du tout au sérieux elle lui
dit mes mecs c'est juste la porte du
placard qui est fermée aujourd'hui et le
plein d'inconnus dans la maison il y en
a peut-être jusqu'à fermer la porte en
partant faire rien de bizarre mais
victor il insiste il insiste il insiste
il a vraiment eu peur et du coup sa mère
réveille son père et son père prend son
fusil et descend on est aux états unis
c'est pour ça une fois en bas après un
petit silence le père de victor ordonne
à victor et sa mère d'aller se cacher et
d'appeler la police
quelques minutes plus tard la police
arrive ils fouillent toute la maison ils
fouillent les alentours de la maison et
trouve à air et le père leur expliquer à
tous qu'en fait en descendant il a vu
que la porte du placard était grande
ouverte et que la porte arrière de la
maison l'était aussi
victor a donc été un [ __ ] de génie
parce qu'il y avait vraiment plaque à
aix il avait commencé à s'affoler et à
dire veuillez à quelqu'un le mec aurait
réagi de manière sûre quoi qu'il en soit
c'est vraiment bas dans ce tout de gens
qui sont chez toi qui sont là qui se
cache qui viennent avec des intentions
qu'on ne connaît pas c'est horrible à
l'étang de passer la deuxième histoire
c'est celle de julia ce qui est drôle
c'est qu'elle a su que récemment donc
des années plus tard ce qui s'était
vraiment passé ce jour là je m'explique
à l'époque les parents du il a travaillé
jusqu'à tard le soir et du coup ils
rentraient pas avant 20 heures
donc à partir de la sixième quand le bus
déposent et julia fallait qu'elle marche
seul pendant cinq minutes pour atteindre
la maison et ensuite elle faisait la
routine habituelle elle explique qu'ils
étaient jouer à des jeux en ligne sur
l'ordi et regarder la télé quelques fois
le chat du voisin venait dans la cour
arrière de la maison de julia et elle
sortait pour le caresser un peut il
nourrir la maison dans laquelle elle
vivait julia c'est une maison dans
laquelle il y avait beaucoup de fenêtres
ce qui est très cool en plein jour parce
que c'est très lumineux ce qui est moins
cool le soir parce que si t'as pas de
stores tout le monde voit ce qui se
passe dans la maison bref tout ça pour
dire que globalement avec toutes ces
fenêtres on voyait très bien tout ce qui
se passait dans la maison y compris
quand julien était seul un soir julia
rentrent de l'école elle descend du bus
comme d'hab
elle marche 5 minutes dans le noir
jusqu'à chez elle comme d'hab elle fonce
dans le bureau de son père elle allume
le redis elle tape c'est meilleur game
sauf que ce jour là après environ 30
minutes de jeu julien entend des
miaulements venir de l'extérieur alors
elle met son jeu en pause elle se lève
elle va voir la fenêtre si elle voit
quelque chose pensons que c'est le chat
de son voisin une fois de plus qui va
lui demander à manger des caresses mais
ya pas de chat et a pas de sangliers
n'ont plus alors elle sera soit elle
reprend sa game et de nous voir
miaulements alors elle se lève cette
fois elle va voir à travers la deuxième
fenêtre du bureau de se faire et
toujours rien ce petit jeu là va durer
environ 10 minutes jusqu'à ce qu'elle
soit sous les et qu'elle aille dans le
salon pour se poser devant la télé est
pareil
au bout de deux minutes il ya des
miaulements qui viennent de la fenêtre
elle commence à prendre un peu peur et
elle court dans sa chambre pour lire un
livre et les miaulements la suivent
jusqu'à sa chambre
puisqu'ils viennent maintenant de la
fenêtre de l'extérieur de sa chambre le
chat harcèle littéralement julia donc
elle appelle son père pour lui expliquer
ce qui vient de se passer et son père
lui explique qui va demander aux voisins
devenir checker puisqu'il lui il est au
travail qui peut pas équivalent à
rappeler dix minutes plus tard son père
l'a rappelle et lui expliquent qu'ils
rentrent à la maison il n'est pas du
tout stressé ou en panique il lui
explique juste que son travail a été
annulé et du coup ce soir ait pu rentrer
plus tôt une heure plus tard son père
arrive à la maison et entre temps et
réalise que les miaulements avait
complètement arrêté
voilà ce qui s'est passé à l'époque
quelques jours avant de raconter ça
julia a enfin su la vérité sur cette
histoire
en fait elle a abordé le sujet en mode
[ __ ] c'était marrant cette histoire de
xala et qui miaulait qui miaulait goethe
avait même appelé et son père lui avouer
la vérité en fait le voisin de julia
était bel et bien venu voir autour de la
maison s'y trouvait son chat est en fait
il n'a pas du tout trouvé un chat il a
trouvé deux grosses empreintes de pas
tout autour de la maison très très
collés aux murs de la maison pour pas
être vus depuis les fenêtres
en fait il ya quelqu'un qui avait suivi
julia jusqu'à chez elle puisque souvenez
vous elle faisait un bout du trajet tout
seul et cette personne elle faisait des
bruits cha pour que julia sortent de
chez elles
en voyant les traces de pas et on
constate ansa le voisin du coup il a
direct rappelé le père de julia et c'est
pour ça que le père de julia est rentré
du travail
immédiatement elle explique qu'il a même
passé tout les jours qui ont suivi avec
elle à la maison tellement il a eu peur
pour elle ils ont bien évidemment appelé
la police sauf que les traces de pas
s'arrêter à partir d'un certain endroit
et du coup ils n'ont jamais pu savoir
qui était là et pourquoi
mais grosso modo c'était une technique
de quelqu'un qui compte est kidnappé
julia c'est le tous les pères et mères
de familles qui sont dans la vidéo
courage ça va allez vous en faites pas
et bien voilà c'est la fin de cette
vidéo serait d'avoir vous at elle plus
tard brésil maintenant je vais pas
d'aidé que j'entends chat miauler je
vais me dire qui est accroupi au pied du
mur père guide maps et ça suffit écoutez
pour la prochaine vidéo ça d'horreur
j'ai une petite idée on va la faire avec
des invités avec des vrais gens qui vont
venir raconter pour de vrai un truc
creepy qu'ils ont vécu comme ça aussi je
pourrais leur poser des questions
revenir sur quelques éléments et en
savoir un peu plus et creusé à mort ces
histoires je sais déjà qui va venir j'ai
des potes en tête qu'ont vécu des trucs
creepy horrible et je pense ça peut être
intéressant de faire évoluer le format
est de faire un truc parfois avec guest
pourquoi pas voilà ça c'était du petit
teasing pour la prochaine bref même si
côté pas bien pas des gens mal
intentionnés à tous les coins de rue
j'espère en tout cas
mais il est vrai que ça arrive alors
voilà méfiez vous
en tout cas soyez pas naïfs n'ayez pas
une confiance aveugle envers quelqu'un
que vous connaissez pas c'est jamais bon
coin envers les youtuber par exemple
c'est alors la halle et attire une
prochaine vidéo
c'est un gros chat j'éteins la lumière
aux platines chiffres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]